he'll stuck will be for furniture Z eval
welcome to you
[Music]
hey youtubers the flash totally did all
the things there's so many big season 4
things they tease as well as stuff that
they did before the actual finale let's
break it down there's a new round of the
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video
that flash burning is not going to help
them right now you kind of see what they
did here they had this big build-up
buried throughout the episode was making
really weird choices oh I'm going to
break all these rules that I created for
myself and then Captain cold give him
that big idea at the end hey you know
don't try to beat him at his own game
the greatest thing about you is your
goodness so it just lets you know that
there's no gun that's going to be able
to stops avatar so they even said it
during the episode it sounded like a
throwaway line but turns out Salvatore
was not wrong but so many comic book
Easter eggs so we'll start with number
10 Cisco and Barry find out that Argus
has the dominator power source that's
leftover from the big mid-season
crossover Lyla pulls this really hard
line look Barry you did a flashpoint is
this because of baby Sara I loved all
the jokes about that it's still a bit of
a sore point for Diggle even though they
have John Diggle jr. the potential
future Connor Hawke now the connor hawke
debated all legends of tomorrow was sort
of like a post-apocalyptic alternate
timeline version so who knows if we'll
ever see him again but I do think that
whatever future they come to he will
become Connor Hawke no matter what so
take from that what you will but there
was like a bit of a crossover with arrow
at the very light way they did it with
the text at the beginning where Felicity
was helping Cisco with all the satellite
work there was a whole bunch of Lila
during the episode and I loved that the
fact that they were able to use her so
much because she's a great actress and
she's a huge character now that she's
the Amanda Waller for the air overs so
if you're not a big comic book person
obviously you know about the Suicide
Squad because they literally called it
out during the episode but there are a
lot of characters from the flash comics
core flash villains that had been
members of the Suicide Squad over the
years including King shark so even
though arrow gave birth to the very
first version of the team the flash has
just as much claim to them as anyone
else so we'll talk about them in a
second Suicide Squad stuff is season 4
stuff so they're teasing a whole bunch
of stuff in this episode and that was
just one of the biggest things but
number 9 Barry needs to pull the hayek
so he goes
he gets captain call from legends of
tomorrow Siberia in the 1800s so the
only other time that they were in
Siberia and season one was when they had
that firestorm episode with Valentina
Vostok she merges with Martin Stein to
become the female firestorm if you
remember she's the actress from mr.
robot she did a great job but it was way
back during season one so this is the
version of Captain Cold that hasn't
sacrificed himself at the end of the
episode when he says no strings on me
that was the line that he said during
the legend season 1 finale when he
sacrificed his life for the rest of the
team no strings on me so the deal with
this version of captain Colt is that
when heatwave brought him back at the
end of legend season 2 he wiped his mind
so this version of Captain cold doesn't
know about anything that happened during
season 2 even though reverse-flash went
back and pulled him out of time so he's
been all over the place the last couple
of seasons I know it's kind of confusing
but they ended on good terms and Captain
Cold is still on the way to becoming a
hero during that season one of legends
timeline but lovely introduction
love the taken reference I need somebody
with a particular set of skills captain
Cole just rolls in with the biggest
smile on his face I always love it when
he's on the show he's such a core
character he'll always come back even if
they had to have some crazy time-travel
explainer but number 8 everybody is
starting to get pissed at Barry because
he broke his time-travel rule again this
is what got you into trouble in the
first place and it starts to steam
during the episode where Barry has a
choice to make
like he chooses to almost try and kill
king shark until Captain colds like dude
we can do this another way you don't
have to kill him so that's also going to
play into how Barry defeats avatar in
the finale Captain Cold gave him the
speech beat him with your true power the
power of hope but on the route to Barry
sort of figuring that out he did all
kinds of fun stuff and it's kind of the
same thing for Cisco when he moves into
that final fight with Caitlin it's time
for me to face hurts very obi-wan Kenobi
Darth Vader Death Star fight like it
makes it seem like somebody's going to
end up dying and it's all playing out as
he's vibed it in the past so it's like
oh my god he's going to lose his hands
any minute now
but it's all about teasing a way of
getting rid of the problem without
having to kill them just like king shark
style Cisco does not have to kill
Caitlin in order to prove
from going completely sideways number
seven though that killer Frost's avatar
scene that was so much fun so you learn
a little bit about savat are outside of
the costume we haven't had too many
scenes of him just standing around when
he's not trying to be fearsome very
damaged my suit and you see Caitlyn
slowly try to talk him out of killing
iris do you really want to do this there
was a version of you that loved her and
he just explains that he thought that he
was disposable he created me just so
that he could throw me away when he was
done with me so why should I care about
him those types of scenes are for all
the people who are like why would any
version of Barry ever want to kill Iris
they wants avatar to feel like he's been
completely abandoned by the people that
love them in the only recourse is to
become a God so that you can free
yourself from all these feelings but
that sounds like a bit of a red herring
like even becoming a god wouldn't really
get rid of your pain you would probably
experience everything simultaneously but
number six welcome back Harrison wells
from earth-2 it's so awesome for them to
have tip to that and I'm expecting to
see Jessie quick back for the finale as
well as Jay Kerry pretty much every big
flash character that you haven't seen in
a while and you're like hey wait a
minute what happened to that person Jay
Garrick is just the biggest one because
he's still stuck in the speedforce
prison right now but they get like a
critical piece of technology from him as
he's working on it and they also use it
as an opportunity to stash iris but
number five
Barry pretending to be Lyla with the
face changing devices they break in this
is very important they're teeing up core
concepts that are going to pay off in
the finale the face changers that HR
used earlier this year seemed like a bit
of a throwaway joke comes back becomes a
really important thing in this episode
might also come into play because HR
feels like he hasn't contributed he
feels like a failure you've given so
much to me this is my home I met the
woman that I'm in love with now what
could I possibly give to you of value so
he could probably give his life so
somebody's going to die in the finale I
feel like all the HR storyline in this
episode was building towards that
sacrifice but you guys can let me know
just for HR storyline there's a bunch of
big questions for characters that need
to be answered in the finale but I feel
like his is pretty clear like yeah he
definitely wants to play the hero Cisco
said at the end of the episode you
always show up when we need you in Barry
doesn't know about anything that happens
they were planning so Asbury was seeing
iris die at the end of the episode there
could have been things that happened
that make it so that our version of iris
isn't dead but somebody did kill iris in
this moment or somebody who looked like
iris so because they actually did kill
iris at the end of the episode there's
obviously going to be some huge twist in
the finale I was so happy the way they
ended the episode such a powerful moment
like you've lost at least from Barry's
perspective were meant to view this
moment from his perspective but number
four there's still so much in the
episode unpack meet your new Suicide
Squad so we have cheetah we have Grodd
king shark in Cupid so what they're
saying here is is that if they do
Suicide Squad next year this is what
it's going to look like but because that
is a lot of CG characters including
Cupid that's going to be freaking
expensive so I'm going to call it right
now biggest prediction for season four
if they pay that off because they tee
things up like that like the in season
one when they show you the flash museum
they show you killer frost big things
from the flash comics that they slowly
pay off we got killer frost now I feel
like they'll pay this off eventually
in what they'll do is they'll use it for
like a two-part episode because it costs
them so much money does they have to
amortize the cost of doing all that CG
over two episodes so just plan on
Suicide Squad stuff happening next
season at least on the flash but maybe
on arrow as well because they called it
out now they got to pay it off there
were all kinds of jaws joke so obviously
they took a dig at the jaws movie they
didn't have enough money to make it look
good so that's why they never showed it
full on yes that's true of the Steven
Spielberg movie but the flash TV show
also does not have a lot of money so
they were kind of making fun of
themselves they couldn't show king shark
full on for too much time so that was
really what they were making fun up they
had the jaws music you it was great I
love it when the flash is hitting all
those bases you know it's really funny
but there's this big dramatic moment
number three even more season four set
up where HR invites Tracy on the team
flash formerly they have this big moment
they have that giant coffee machine and
obviously I think that she's going to
stick around for season four but it
really feels like setup to pull the rug
out from under us and HR will end up
dying in the finale but number two
saboteur finds out where iris is shows
up on earth to Rex
totally wrecks Wally so he is
incapacitated for
finale take Cyrus terrorizes the team
don't call me that name in the number
one everybody moves into place and Barry
is forced to live out that moment with
Iris dying again even though he has the
gun and Ghostbusters style just fires at
him it totally looks like the proton
pack from Ghostbusters in sabot are just
shrugs it off with sabotage saying that
he's had infinite amounts of time to
learn how to utilize the Speed Force so
he knows how to counteract it and then
explains that the Philosopher's Stone is
part of the key to it because it is a
calcified piece of Speed Force energy so
we finally learn the secret of the
Philosopher's Stone why it's able to
give people powers who have powers
during flashpoint unlock them the Speed
Force husks because the Dark Matter
explosion is what gave people their
powers in the first place and that's
basically Speed Force just peppered
throughout the city so touching the
stone would be like drinking a Speed
Force milkshake that'd be crazy for
speedsters so it makes them that much
more powerful there were so many other
great moments in the episode I don't
want to turn this into like a 50 minute
long video when iris was talking to Joe
about being kids oh you know when I was
a kid I lied I tried to sneak out that's
why I switched room with Barry he tells
her about the Blues cruise that he went
on such great moments so let me know in
the comments what was your favorite
moment in the episode you know even
though there's like a lot of stuff that
I didn't include in the episode but
obviously in Fantino Street last big
Easter Egg is Carmine Infantino the
person who created most of the big
Rogues that you've seen on the flash
including the reverse-flash himself so
obviously what's going to happen next is
I'll do a trailer video for next week's
episode and I'll try to answer some of
the big questions that we have like how
could I restore be alive in season 4 if
we just saw her die there's going to be
a big twist one of two things just
happened either HR found a way to swap
himself for iris and face change or she
really did die and Barry is going to
have to petition the Speed Force and
that will be part of the bargain that he
makes in serve his penance is a way to
bring I respect because if he can go
into the Speed Force he can prevents
avatar from becoming savat are so little
retro actively fix the timeline in iris
won't be dead she'll just magically come
back I'll say congratulations to
Christopher Rodriguez you're the latest
giveaway winner please private message
be on the back end of my channel so I
can get your content
details you can click here for that
blast trailers that has more footage for
the finale and click here for new
Justice League and to learn about the
Doomsday Clock the Jeff John's just
tease thank you so much for watching so
let's high-five I'll see you guys
tonight
you